si vous voyez aujourd'hui dans ce décor
de régis de la télévision française
c'est que notre émission va justement se
dérouler à la télévision nous avons reçu
beaucoup de lettres de jeunes filles de
petite fille qui voudrait avoir des
renseignements sur le métier de
speakerine de la télévision vous pensez
que répondre à ces questions là est très
simple puisque nos amis les speakerines
sont justement ici
vous venez de voir il ya un instant
jacqueline cora elle est là dans le
petit studio habituel des speakerines de
la télévision elle s'occupe de ces
annonces de tout à l'heure mais sont là
pour l'instant si vous voulez nous
allons entrebâillé la porte de la loge
de catherine langeais
bonjour catherine danger majeur pierre
la porte grince et comme dans les films
policiers
catherine nous avons beaucoup de
correspondances dinan de parler de ce
métier de speakerine
qu'est ce que c'est cette profession
alors là je vous arrête tout de suite
parce que je trouve que le mot
profession est parfaitement sains
propres ce qui concerne les speakerines
en effet je crois plutôt qu'il s'agit
d'un rôle que nous jouerons dans un
grand ensemble à grand spectacle en
quelque sorte qu'ils aient la télévision
il y a donc un certain nombre de ses
rôles de speakerine une fois que les
places sont pourvus gagnant n'a plus
d'autre à moins que l'une d'entre nous
dont malade on disparaît suhner pour des
raisons que nous ne pouvons pas imaginer
pour l'instant mais sans cela il n'y a
pas à pourvoir de place il faut que tout
le monde se disent bien qu' on ne vient
pas le dire je veux explique répit
demain on va l'être non c'est impossible
de même que le président de la
république joue un rôle et qui a pas
d'école pour être président de la
république et northern et comme par
exemple pierre qui sont la thèse en
l'occurrence mai
résidant dans l'ue et effectivement il
ya une seule place en on est peut être
candidat à présidence de la république
tous les sept ans que ça peut arriver
mais en fait d'une façon générale on n'a
pas élire le président de la république
comme ça et puis là d'ailleurs c'est une
profession qui ne dure que c'est un fait
certain mais oui à la rascasse
occasion-là je vais vous dire il va
falloir je me fasse rêver parce que ça
fait sept ans que je suis clean ont mis
4 et 9 avril à l'unanimité on savait on
avait l'impression que n'est-il pas que
depuis huit semaines
dites moi cette profession cependant
elle existe quand même terrifiant
domaine relations qui existent pour
quelques demi douzaine de jeunes femmes
en france et est ce que c'est une
profession très plaisante et très facile
et bien écoutez et plaisante
dans un certain sens facile par trait
est déplaisante par d'autres présente
parce que vraiment elle nous éclaire la
sympathie de beaucoup de gens et c'est
vraiment très gentil quand nous
promenant dans la rue
nous rencontrons des milliers de
personnes qui nous disent nous ayons
bien ce qui ne nous aiment pas ne nous
abordent pas c'est déjà quelque chose
car il ya forcément des gens qui nous
aiment pas enfin ceci de ce côté-là et
plaisant par ailleurs ce qui est
déplaisant c'est tout de même tous les
inconvénients
nous avons la lumière dans les yeux et
une lumière extrêmement violente même
lorsque sur l'écran on a l'impression
qu'on n'est pas très éclairé il y a les
heures que nous passons dans les studios
avant les émissions il y à la mémoire
tout de même qu'il faut pas voir parce
que il faut tout de même retenir les
les aurait enfin il y à mille choses qui
ne sont pas toujours plus indépendants
rien vous cacher c'est une profession
qui n'est pas tellement bien payé mais
bientôt il va y avoir aussi un point
très délicat ce sont les annonces de
vous devez faire brusquement quand il ya
un incident oui vous est prévu très
attendu tout l'incident il arrive
brusquement notre annonce est peut-être
très brusque aussi des biens ou des
cadres et comme affirme d'expérience on
a demandé à la régie finale de faire de
faire faire une annonce d' excuses qui
ne passera pas sur antenne dieu merci il
ya dans une fosse avance d'excusé de la
faire faire par jacqueline caux rock et
justement service en ce moment
jacqueline représentant romand
j'écoute leurs portes a su nous devions
transmettre depuis saint-etienne à 15
heures est annulé par suite du mauvais
temps alors voulez-vous faire une
annonce d' excuses auprès de vos
téléspectateurs et leur annoncer à la
place le film un film s'appellera la
chasse aux canards
un court métrage évidemment bon alors
vous la tension vous donnera les
indications volant vous d'accord
chers amis nous sommes vraiment navré
mais le reportage que nous avions prévu
pour 15h reportage au sportif retransmis
depuis saint-etienne est annulé par
suite du mauvais temps vous voudrez bien
nous excuser de la suppression de ce
programme et vous vous rendez compte que
c'est vraiment indépendant de notre
volonté
à la place nous vous proposons un film
un film sur la chasse aux canards
catherine voici d'autres questions nous
avons adoré de l'île de 26 ans
remariée vote respectif avec deux t elle
n'a qu'à regarder jacqueline escoffier
de courbevoie demande il est difficile
de vaincre sa timidité
je ne sais pas s'il peut être question
de timidité je crois de trac en tout cas
moi je les ai eu pendant très longtemps
je crois que vous arrivez à peu près à
20khz maintenant jamie denise ravon de
paris que faites-vous durant les
émissions à sa naissance éléments
variables en tout cas nous sommes
obligés de rester dans notre petit
studio précisément pour intervenir comme
vous venez de le voir et de l'entente en
cas de pépin et puis nous avons notre
tricoter sinon voulons donc posée puis
aussi de regarder les émissions c'est ce
que je fais en général je viens ma salle
de bain nu demande des speakerines
listel sur un grand tableau ou
apprennent dès leur annonce par coeur à
ça cette question je suis contente
qu'elle me la posent car elle m'a été
posée très très très souvent et je crois
que ça intrigue pas mal de gens pas
seulement les enfants daniel non nous
n'avons pas de tableaux d'ailleurs ce ne
serait pas possible car pour lire sur un
tableau ne pourrions pas regarder
exactement dans la caméra autrement dit
nous ne donnerions pas l'impression aux
gens de leur parler directement
par conséquent nous ne lisons pas nous
avons quelquefois un petit papier à côté
de nous sur une table qui nous permet en
cas de trop complet de jeter un petit
coup d'oeil mais nous devons apprendre
tous nos programmes
en résumé catherine qu'est ce que l'on
doit exiger d'une bonne speakerine à ce
qu'on a exigé d'une bonne feeling c'est
plutôt directeur des programmes que vous
devriez demander ça enfin d'abord une
culture générale
je crois en principe le bachot
c'est-à-dire être capable de tomber sur
des mots
étrangers sans but et pouvoir les
prononcer quand j'ai passé mon goncourt
moi je suis tombé sur marina l'init à
rabat il seulement ou est resté vraiment
dans un miroir
c'est une danseuse un double jeu vous
avez ou que j'ai un tout petit peu
trébuché comme je suis tombé sur ce mot
et puis comme autre qualité bien ne pas
être trop laide je crois ensuite être
tout de même assez bien vêtu le plus
souvent posée mais ça c'est difficile
parce que nous n'avons aucun fret des
fremm donc un défraiement
par conséquent c'est tout à notre charge
alors être habillée de façon à plaire à
tous
et ça c'est très difficile parce qu'il
ya des gens qui aiment les choses
compliquées d'autres qui aime les choses
simples
je crois que c'est à peu près tout et
puis aussi et ça alors c'est peut-être
la première qualité même avoir de la
mémoire
oui et justement catherine nous allons
maintenant assister à un test un test
qui a été passé sur une jeune fille
parce qu'on vous fait qu en compte tout
de même qu'on engage par speakerine mais
je pense qu'on prépare des réserves de
ski gressier je peux être écrasé tout
al'air incertain mais une jeune fille a
passé la tête et quelques jours et
justement galement de réciter tous les
programmes de la journée si vous voulez
nous allons là et que temps là je vais
vous demander maintenant une petite
expérience que vous avez je crois plus
préparé un petit peu malheureusement pas
aussi bien qu'on aurait voulu mais et
dans des conditions qui sont toujours un
peu pressés qui sont celles des
speakerines qui reçoit son texte
rapidement un peu de temps avant
l'émission
alors je vous mets en est en préparation
des missions attention à vous bonjour
mesdames
bonjour mademoiselle bonjour messieurs
la télévision française vous souhaite
une bonne journée dominicale et vous
propose une série d'émissions qui nous
l'espérons satisferont les goûts les
plus divers à 15 heures
vous nous vous proposons la séquence du
spectateur
puis nos émissions reprendront à 14h30
avec
pardon c'était d'avoir le trap pour moi
14h30 avec notre émission enfantine en
tout pour les jeunes parce qu enfantine
ça fait vraiment trop trop jeune par
monts et par vaux à 15h10 jean noir et
henri leclerc ou propose 36 chansons de
pierre du dedans
à 15h45 le reportage sportif
tout d'abord le tennis au stade roland
garros puis ensuite au cyclisme au parc
des princes marianne le sun est-ce que
vous souvenez vous de votre examen de
passage votre panneau d'entrée rentrée
si oui je m'en souviens c'était pas
vraiment être très amusant d'ailleurs
alors l'avait eu des annonces à faire on
m'avait préparé des annonces enfin vous
avez dit telle ou telle émission vous
avancerez alors le jour j'arrivais
j'avais une puce mois peut parler de ça
alors je commence puis tout d'un coup on
dit non le dessin animé là pas lieu mais
il faut vous annonciez à l'interview de
tel ou tel ministre alors j'ai
textuellement annoncé et bien à la place
du dessin animé nous avons le plaisir de
vous présenter à l'interview de monsieur
mouvement serait faire c'est pas de ta
gestion
non maintenant vous juriez beaucoup
mieux j'en suis sûr dis moi il ya la
petite nicole bros de chartres qui nous
pose une question très précise sur vous
elle sait que vous avez été comédienne
avant d'être speakerine voudrais savoir
quelles sont les grosses différences
qu'il ya pour vous entre ces deux
métiers
tout d'abord on est on est entièrement
seul en plus c'est précis mobile plus
qu'il faut parler face et une caméra
sans trop bouger beaucoup et puis aussi
les qu'une question de textes enfin que
ce que souvent quand on annonce faite
tout les horaires uniquement sont pas
dire c'est un véritable texte me battrai
un peu monotone bien 12h45 13h15
d'ailleurs j'ai l'impression que les
gens n'écoutent pas tellement ça parce
que c'est trop rapide et trop précis
j'aime bien bien et puisqu'il ya aussi
sans doute c'est que la comédienne est
obligé d'interpréter un personnage qui
n'est brel en général tandis que l'art
vous efforcer d'être le plus possible
puisque je suis ma gueule de seine dans
la vie
exactement et il y a aussi une question
très intéressante c'est géraldine ma
boucle et d'autres petites filles
d'ailleurs qui nous demandent quel est
le maquillage que vous employez il y
avait un temps un maquillage très
compliqué avec du coup
mr bien vous attend vous n'étiez pas là
font savoir non quand même pas mais là
maintenant ça dépend un peu catherine se
maquille avais je pas choquer là une
sorte de fondeurs jacqueline aussi moi
je mets plutôt de la poudre enfin ça
dépend aussi une question de peau et de
ce que ça donne mais l'électronique ou
c'est à dire qu'il ya des maquilleuses
qui ont dû faire des essais et aricie
sur chacune d'entre vous et la blonde et
la brune n'utilise pas bien sûr les
mêmes choses on peut pourvoir pour
maquiller
oui on entre dans le secret salut je
suis pas très facile à kiev et fait très
mal qu'est ce que vous faites dans
l'oeil de biche gros de biche oui
j'avais toujours trop faut pas laisser
quelqu'un qui tombe et l'autre car vous
vous êtes bien gentils marianne dites
moi il ya une chose que nous voudrions
présenter aux jeunes téléspectateurs
ce sont les speakerines des régions de
france car on connaît surtout les
speakerines nationale qui travaille qu'à
paris mais il ne faut pas oublier qu'il
ya d'autres speakerine charmante fouet
dont l'échéance n'est que par exemple
les strasbourgeois ne connaissent pas la
speakerine de marseille ou de l'un ou de
la speakerine de lyon ne venait pas de
ce qu'elle décline alors si vous voulez
on va grâce à la télévision faire un
petit résumé des speakerines de france
inclusive strasbourg jacqueline ceinture
elle licence de droit elle prépare
actuellement une thèse de doctorat en
droit clients lucienne blanc bernard
mariée mère de trois enfants
comédienne lille
josiane bouchet études secondaires au
lycée de l'île études infirmières d'état
marié à lille aussi
christiane rabier gars d'origine
polonaise baccalauréat de philosophie
licence d'anglais certificat de polonais
joue du piano
enfin à marseille anne marie peysson
elle voulait être comédienne elle devint
speakerine jacqueline nous voilà revenus
dans le studio que l'on appelle le
studio de complément vous savez nous
avons reçu beaucoup de questions qui
vous concerne et une petite fille
particulièrement voudrais savoir si vous
aimez mieux présenter les émissions
l'après-midi ou le soir
ah voilà une question assez délicate
parce que je dois dire que sur le plan
personnel cela met absolument égal
toutefois
une petite préférence pour le soir quand
même parce que sur le plan artistique
que c'est plus intéressant nous avons
des émissions plus grande à porter plus
conséquent si je veux mettre mes ainsi
est vraiment c'est un plus grand plaisir
mais d'un autre côté et bien voyez vous
il n'y a absolument aucune différence
puisque nous sommes dans un studio vous
y êtes vous pouvez le constater il n'y a
absolument aucune ouverture aucune
fenêtre
il n'y a pas la lumière du jour par
conséquent nous sommes deux jours sous
celle des projecteurs et on ne peut pas
différencier midi de minuit c'est cela
il ya cependant une après midi que vous
aimez particulièrement à cela bien sûr
pierre et c'est celle du jeudi nous
sommes jeudi et vous savez que là
vraiment c'est un très très grand
plaisir pour moi d'accueillir tous nos
petits téléspectateurs de tous les coins
de force et vraiment c'est mon émission
préférée je viens voyez-vous tous les
jeunes téléspectateurs voient en ce
moment le studio choses qu'ils ne
connaissent guère car ils vous voient
dans le studio mais ne savent pas ce
qu'il ya autour de vous qu'est ce que
c'est que cette table où il ya votre sac
et des journaux alors là c'est la table
où nous nous plaçons nous pouvons faire
un empire accord oui mais au delà c'est
notre petit tiers voire à manille là il
ya le poudrier il ya le fond de teint le
rouge à lèvres aussi l'espagne enfin
tout ce qui nous permet de nous mettre
en beauté avant d'apparaître
mais on avait guère besoin que celle-ci
crcc deux choses c'est de tout poil qui
a devancé les microbes est trop gentil
pour nos micros 1113 esthétique
oui non mais c'est très curieux comment
ils sont des choses auxquelles on n'est
pas habitué dans la vie c'est vrai c'est
la grande feuille que vous avez sur
cette table devant vous alors cette
grande faille c est ce que nous appelons
le conducteur des émissions voyez-vous
avant de présenter nos émissions nous
remet sur ce papier sur lequel sont
indiquées tous les horaires des
émissions que nous aurons à présenter
aussi les noms des réalisateurs et j'ai
employé le terme horreur c'est vraiment
ça voyez vous on est un petit peu comme
un chef de quart qui doit connaître par
coeur les horaires de ses trains et à
nous évidemment de le présenter à nos
téléspectateurs d'une façon agréable
dites moi qu'est ce que c'est la grosse
boîte qui a sur la table
la grosse voire à cette boîte l'air
c'est notre interphone alors voyez vous
il ya des tas de petits boutons et cela
nous permet de communiquer avec la régie
finale de poser des questions au moment
d'une émission ou au moment d'une chose
inattendue s'il faut par exemple si il a
été décidé qu'un internaute doit passer
entre deux émissions nous demandons
quelle sera cette interlude et ça permet
aussi aux gens de la régie finale de
communiquer avec nous nous recevons les
heures pour vous les entendez par ou
yahoo parleur mais oui ia ou parler
retournez-vous pierre vous allez y voir
là bas vous cette grande bouamri avec un
trou dans le mur et à côté je vois
d'ailleurs les choses fortes
intéressantes j'aperçois la pendule de
l'horloge parlante et vous la
reconnaissez
il remet en marche avant les émissions
c'est aussi un rêve exactement sur
l'horloge pas exactement à nos
opérateurs est en contact avec l'horloge
parlante reçoit l'heure exacte et
l'indic sur la bande il et il ya encore
on le studio des projecteurs bien sûr et
un récepteur sur lequel vous contrôlez
votre image cet examen hier
parce que voyez vous je crois que c'est
amusant de signaler nous n'avons pas de
cameraman ou nous cadrons nous mêmes
alors nous sommes sur notre petit siège
et en regardant cette image de contrôle
et bien nous voyons exactement où nous
devons nous placer si nous sommes sont
pas droites pour pago gérant général
nous essayons de respecter le centre est
effectivement cette caméra qui est
devant vous la et une caméra tout seul
sans caméraman et bien maintenant chers
jacqueline je crois qu'il est temps de
nous quitter nous allons vous retrouver
dans un instant car l'autre émission
arrive à sa fin j'aimerais aussi ainsi
que marianne de seine et catherine
langeais d'avoir répondu si gentiment à
nos questions il ne nous reste plus
maintenant qu'à passer notre générique
de fin eh bien c'est ce que nous allons
faire
or vert pierre a tout de suite a tout de
suite c'est vrai